New York best-selling author we're going
to do the mythbuster quiz how's that new
york bestselling author
Laura Dora how are you I'm great
it's good to be here and travel me that
thank you for being with funds we're
going to get we're going to keep it
exciting we're going to get into a quiz
you do a quiz in your book then on many
of them syndicated mainstream media
outlets talking about you know the
success that you've had we'll get into
the science behind it I want to ask you
about that but I want to make it fun
here where people can participate
wherever they're tuning in if you're
with your your beloved spouse angry
spouse whatever it and they're tuning in
and now they're going to take we're
going to do the mythbuster quiz how's
that all right
tort or false and now I'm going to I'm
going to go ahead and ask the question
that you have to straight from your book
empowered wife I'm going to ask the
question and then give the right answer
and then you'll comment on it how's that
okay so the first one we're getting into
is now you guys at home now you're going
to be don't cheating alright so you keep
score on your own I can't keep it for
you so true or false all right these are
myth busters I'm asked a question and
then either true or false and then tally
it up and see who wins at the end first
one you ready all right marriage is hard
work
you guys got right now two seconds
you're done okay answer is false
and you go ahead and comment I've been
married for 25 years and my marriage is
a soft place to land waitressing is hard
work writing a book is hard work working
out is hard work but a marriage is a
piece of cake and then you say
now that I have the right skills
keypoint here can you go ahead and take
it from here absolutely before I learned
the intimacy skills my marriage did feel
like hard work we were bickering all the
time we were butting heads a lot in fact
I was right on the brink of divorce but
if you think about it if you gave a 16
year old the keys to the car cause he
said oh you're 16 now you're old enough
to drive and you never have them take
any driving lessons or learn the rules
of the road they would probably crash
the car too and they would go WOW
driving is really dangerous maybe right
and so my relationship felt really hard
just because I didn't have the right
training but now is this is where I find
out that I'm beautiful and special and
wonderful and it husband kisses better
much so it seems really easy now that I
know the rules of the road yeah you talk
about that in your book I mean if you if
you how many accidents will we have if
you just like what you talk about you
threw the keys to the the people driving
they didn't go through the classes the
rules of the road and you know how to be
a responsible driver and most people get
into marriage you know and we don't have
any we don't have what you talked about
those necessary skills yeah it's
absolutely true that when I first
learned about them I would really kind
of set at my female relatives you know
my mom's and my grandma's I mean my mom
and my grandmother because why didn't
you tell me this information but sadly I
don't think they knew it either I think
it really is kind of a secret and that
most people don't know the intimacy
skill that's why it's so important to me
to make sure every woman happen because
I really suffered unnecessarily you know
when I was in college there was no
relationships 101 class and my textbooks
were Cosmo magazine and Glamour magazine
and of course that didn't get me the
kind of relationship that I dreamed up
the one that I have now yeah okay so
that's you guys either you said too or
false you call that one of the
Mythbusters and it doesn't have to
because that's another important thing I
mean you come home and you've worked all
day and Viet the husband or wife you
don't that
is I mean really draining
psychologically you could have had a
long eight-hour day but now to be
fighting and bickering that becomes a
lot of work you know managing all that
stuff so it shouldn't be like that hi in
the six intimacy skills helped to give
you the skills to be able to make it
where it's not like a full-time job it's
not that hard strenuous that's right one
of the things that we see a lot is that
women will say my husband's always
working all he does is spend his time at
work and sometimes it's because I've
been just feels more successful at work
he feels like it's getting more positive
reinforcement and more respect and so
that's a more appealing environment for
him than being at home and then once she
starts using the six intimacy skills
I hear reports like oh he comes from
from work early now just to spend time
with me so it can make a big difference
yeah you keep the men many many people
they end up at the pub or somewhere else
it's what people want to go home but now
with these with these six these
principles intimacy skills hopefully we
can get things change God willing okay
moving on to next it's the quiz now okay
straight from her book we're going to go
to the next one
husbands and wives have to give okay
have you heard this one husband's his
wife have to give and take equally for
marriage to succeed okay now look at
each other false or true what's your
answer and I'll give you the one the
correct one according to Laura Doyle
Falls all right and then you comment the
more women receive graciously from their
husbands and focus on their own
happiness the more successful the
marriage will be please elaborate on
this around here is a about a hundred to
ones with my husband giving and
providing and hugging and kissing and
making my tea and putting gas in my car
like I do one thing and he gives me
about a hundred back so it feels really
uneven and that was very awkward for me
at first I thought because I've been
trained that first of all marriage was
hard work and that it was 50/50 or
something to your people
say 100 100 everyone is the divider
percent and so I thought that that meant
that I should find my husband's socks
and underwear and tell them with his
resume and show him how to dress and how
to eat healthier and how to make a
budget and all of that was just causing
distance it was causing strife between
us because when my husband really wanted
was to first of all make me happy which
he does by doing all these wonderful
things for me and he also wanted my
respect and admiration for all the
things and the ways that he took care of
me and so it was much it was such a
relief to find out that that is a much
better arrangement for both of us
because I want to be taken care and I
want to feel desired and I'm happy to
let him do that and that's what he wants
to do too so it's a real eye-opener for
me it was actually pretty shocking to
find out that I don't have to keep up
with all that he's doing for me I like
what you mentioned here focusing when an
individual focuses on their own
happiness
instead of trying to make it dependent
on someone else you highlight that it's
important that you focus on making
yourself happy rather than leaving
yourself powerless depending on someone
else for that happiness yeah sadly I
have gotten into this terrible rut where
I was really concerned with the hub
cleaning and my job and all that is
paying on the build and a lot of
responsibilities and I had turned into a
martyr you know my mother on her wear
sailor I just didn't have much happiness
in my life and I thought it was my
husband's fault and not his job to make
me happy and even if I did it'd be kind
of embarrassing like where did I get
that idea of course that important job
is mine and when I focus on that job of
making myself happy the hump when I
become really attractive to my husband
I'm never hotter all this women when I'm
singing dancing smiling laughing then he
just wants to pile on he's like wow
she's really happy I'm going to do it
and you make her even happier and so it
is a virtuous cycle that just kind of
takes us higher and higher when I just
take time out to do frivolous fun and
you at least three things a day and the
policy every single day to make myself
happy and some days I need even more
than that you're keeping yourself busy
and not just waiting around say okay I'm
going to wait till he comes he'll make
me happy okay exactly what I was doing
before was embarrassed to say but that's
exactly what I did and I see a lot of
women get stuck in this rut as well I
don't know how we get there the solution
is to really like I make it made a list
of 20 things that make me ridiculously
happy when I do that and I just take off
of that list every day like okay I'm
going to do at least these three that
are not necessarily productive things
right like they only serve to make me
happy like if you just having a cup of
coffee with a friend or talking with
just on the phone or playing volleyball
or singing at the top of my lungs for
example all those things are just to
make me feel good but they serve my
marriage magically that's only two we're
going to continue on with the quiz we're
going to continue having fun with this
but this is something serious as you
highlight your mission is to help and
you mentioned this in your book your
your exact words so I don't misquote
them is sharing you know and we're
helping also to share that vision to end
world divorce I mean I don't know forget
it 100% but if we can get that number
down because it's happening every 13
seconds every 13 seconds someone is
getting divorced yeah it's very tragic
and just remember for my sauce when I
was there and wanted to divorce my
husband how painful it was and also now
looking at how unnecessary it was
because now I'm married to the man of my
dreams it's the same man the same man
okay we're going to take a break and and
when we're done with the quiz I'm going
to prove to you that there's science
behind this okay because it's all about
science and whatnot so this is not just
her opinion this has been tested
thousands of peer an international coach
on this helping people from all
thousands of women get desired shares
loved in the door and as a
a success rate we'll talk about that
when we come back we got to finish the
quiz don't go anywhere
we'll be right back oh there's only one
messenger there's only one welcome Jesus
once his messenger Allah back on the D
show with best-selling New York Times
author Laura Doyle with the new book in
Howard wife the empowered wife thank you
again for being on initial thank you let
you're ready to continue are you guys
ready you're ready continue with the
quiz we were at number two let's go on
to another one
women have more okay so this is these
are Mythbusters true or false is it a
reality or fantasy false or fiction true
or false
women have more influence than men on
whether a relationship will be connected
and fun or distant go ahead and think
about true you got it that's what it is
Laura Doyle she goes on to say women are
keepers of the relationship and have
much power over the culture in the home
please comment on this well absolutely
if you think about it from this time we
start as a courtship really men are
asking women out so we have a lot of
power it's almost like you're let's say
you're the director of the Broadway show
you get to say okay this dancer is in or
that one's out we're auditioning men for
the role so that's a very powerful
position and then it continues it as a
relationship develops we we are the
gatekeepers for sex and then it turns
out that we also initiate the most
divorce some studies show this as high
as 90% among college educated women
where the woman has initiated the
divorce or the person is willing to walk
away unfortunately also has the most
power in the relationship and because
men want to make us happy you know I got
thousands event in this question okay
I'm going to this year that your wife
and it's happening back let me ask you
that question let's just let's just get
it on the table right here how important
is it to you that's huge yeah yeah and
so all men say the same they may say it
across every looks across the board is
it robbing you having that you you have
I mean we're going for it's like the
standard but you know you obviously have
exceptions to every rule but we're
talking about the standard right you
know well of all the men I've asked
those men that I asked they all said the
same thing they all said it's like the
most important thing it's everything
whether you have you have some oddball
adult or it's pronounced I'll never I've
never once had anyone say anything any
man say anything except in the UK they
said it's imperative so all over the
world it seems to be the same thing and
so because men just want to make a copy
we have we hold the key we make her so
happy that he's happy and we're happy
and then the relationship is happy and
it kind of stands to reason that only
happy people have happy relationship
what she says why isn't he then making
me happy if you miss uh Laura Doyle you
know you seem to know it all why isn't
he making me happy
that is a great question and that was me
I believe that my husband didn't care
about my happiness early in the marriage
how have you had those situations where
someone will get a little attitude and
snippy with you and it said oh
absolutely and rightly so you know I
think that's the great thing about the
intimacy skills like test them out see
if they work for you that's what I did
it first - I just started experimenting
in my marriage but my husband Clint
makes me happy for two reasons one was
that I was unbelievable in fact it's now
a someone asked him recently like what's
the number what quality you want in
white and he said please ability he
wanted to be able to please me and I
wasn't feasible no matter what he did I
found fault with it like he would clean
the kitchen and I go um well what about
you to wipe off the counters so when he
gonna do that right there wasn't much
appreciation and the other piece is that
he knew that I was not very respectful I
didn't think very highly of my
and I thought that I was the smarter one
I had this superiority complex I thought
gosh I'm just a little a little more
common sense than he does and I'm just a
little better at practically everything
because I like having things in my way
and I'm not proud to say that because
and through this journey I've gained
some humility I'm happy to say and I
didn't even understand why I would want
that before I didn't I didn't know why
you want to be humble and now I can
appreciate I'll give you an example is
just happen we're getting ready for our
tax appointment and the previous tax
year we had put in new windows and air
conditioning and my husband's kind of
famous for like that's a tax deduction
you know the more like oh no notice a
tax deduction and well we make all of
your videos here in the house and the
windows up to soundproof the house and
the air conditioning made it so we can
tape on hot days without you you know
dripping with sweat which happens when
we live down sometimes so after he
explained it I was like oh maybe I is I
mean I don't know we brought it to the
CPA and I'll figure it out but I don't
always know I'm not the big smartypants
that I thought that I was beautiful that
really is I like what you said you said
unpleased well I mean I've had people
say that look no matter what I try
there's no pleasing this person so this
is really profound let's move on to a
number that was three right how are you
guys doing now okay see at the end
you'll be able to tell it up and see who
won the quiz let's move on to number
four a happy wife is often willing to
have intimate relations with her husband
even if she is not in the mood to wear
false guys too or false true and Laura
Doyle comments on this why would you
want to pass up the opportunity to feel
desired to feel pleasure and to connect
with your husband physically emotionally
and spiritually just because you don't
start out in the mood doesn't mean you
won't end up there please comment down
well because my husband just wants to
maybe have
and this also applies in the bedroom and
one of the things that I wasn't very
good at in my early relationship was
saying what I wanted and just even
knowing what I wanted was kind of a
problem at first and so I think what
happens so for the women we're listening
thinking ooh oh my gosh they'll keep one
every day twice a day and we never stop
you would be in bed all the time so of
course you are always in charge of your
own body I can just say what's right for
you but I just know that this part that
happens in the bedroom is what
differentiates a romantic relationship
from every other relationship that you
have you might smell a book with your
kids and you might share things that are
really emotionally sensitive with your
sister or your friends but the one thing
that separates a marriage it makes it
special it's a physical relationship
that we have so it's something that when
it goes missing because some irreparable
harm to the emotional connection as well
as you're passing up this opportunity to
have amazing physical pleasure and just
connection so if it's not that enjoyable
for you if it feels like a chore right
now then I just invite you to consider
the things that would make it more
pleasurable for you and then you can say
those things to him outside the bedroom
you could be out for a walk or having
dinner and you could be having this
really sensual conversation about what
pleases you and how he would be
delighted and he is taking notes on that
he is like a hot okay now I know what my
wife really likes and so as you go along
and continue to express those desires
and then reinforce him when he's
successful with it the whole of that
aspect of your relationship can really
become so much more satisfying and
gratifying okay that was number four
let's move on to number five you talked
about here so this is true or false
we're busting the myths if something
your husband is doing if it's bothering
you it's best to be honest and to say it
directly all right something's bothering
you just tell them let them know what it
is it is true
or false and you say your book empowered
why false you actually say it's false
you don't have to suffer and definitely
but criticism has a chilling effect on
intimacy and there's always a better way
to get what you want please explain
explain this answer to us well so 99.9%
of timer medicine is getting on my very
last nerve and I just want to film is
not about you talking on the phone loud
or if you choose with his mouth open or
something like that it really is a
reflection of my own self care that's
gone lacking I I'm on edge already maybe
I need a nap or maybe I need to go for a
while I need to do something to make
myself happy because of course my
husband's a mere immoral and once no
quality is going to do something that
could be irritating and for the most
part when I make myself happy it's
absolute I don't care it's no big deal
like I'm I'm busy doing my thing and I'm
not really focused on the minor details
of what might have been doing so it's
almost always a sign and I'll ask my
clients my clients a con the con say oh
my husband you know let me get the
kidney sugar and stay in their pajamas
and watch cartoons all morning you know
you can't even trust into the parents
and I'll say something like yeah how's
your self-care and she'll be like oh I
don't have any I'm exhausted
motor well don't work there's too much
to do and then when we sent that right
open her husband goes back to being this
great guy that she married
okay that was five it was that five we
were at five we're going to take a few
more and just giving you a taste of
what's in this this book and we'll get
into the science behind it and a few
more things on this exciting episode
with Laura Doyle best-selling New York
Times author here on the D show don't go
anywhere
there's only one
Mohammed is His Messenger Allah Allah
there's only one welcome Jesus once his
messenger Allah welcome back to the D
show I'm with Laura Doyle then power
wife okay hope you guys are having fun
we'll having a nice quiz and these are
just we give you a taste of what's in
the book much of benefit but as Wayne
Dyer once said I hope you know about him
he said either for the mind to work it
has to be functioning like a parachute
it has to be open and this is extremely
important I understand you know if you
just came on and you're giving your
opinion because of you know your
experience maybe in just one or two
relationship but you have been
international relation coach for how
long now 18 years whoa 18 years okay so
18 year is not someone who okay maybe
you were in and out of a marriage you
divorced two three times and someone's a
look at how she made it work
no you are about to divorce you acquired
the skills you saved your marriage and
then the last program we did you can go
and watch it on our channel we talked
about the fallacy now the myth also and
about how marriage traditional marriage
counseling actually does more harm than
good and you went through that you talk
about it in your book
right which most people they think okay
you go to the to the marriage counselor
and then it's just like a bastion fest
can you touch upon this before we get to
the next quiz question sure yeah there
are a lot of problems there so I I
joined medicine to marriage counseling
because I wanted her to fix him so he
would be a good husband so I could
finally be happy that's how I thought it
work of course it's not how it works but
it isn't hide out for hypocrites if I'm
honest a lot of us don't go I wasn't
trying to self-examine
I was just wanting her fix that guy over
there
never going to work but the other
problem was spending an hour a week
complaining about each other never made
any couple happier and it certainly
didn't work for us and then the other
problem was that because respect is like
oxygen for husband would you agree
respect is pretty important Silvia's so
the first thing that we did was i sat in
front of it stranger the therapist and
told her everything that was wrong with
my husband and there's really nothing
more that you're special I had had done
than to rip them apart in front of this
stranger
so I actually dug my hole a lot deeper
that day they have more defensive and
distant which is the opposite of what I
really was trying to accomplish which is
to feel playful and connected and
restore the passion in my relationship
so just for those three reasons alone
there's more but those are the top three
reasons that marriage counseling
actually does more harm than good and
the tragedy is I didn't know there were
any alternatives to marriage counseling
I don't know that there were many
alternative to marriage counseling when
we were going we went for years we spent
thousands of dollars and all I did was
put further into the ditch why do you
think nowadays when we go more back I
don't see it where it was like this does
the culture this society today you kind
of you kind of you go away from what you
just said to our word respect it's like
people they've learned the songs about
it you know you mentioned that one
comedian like I can't get no respect I
remember we talked about that but
sometimes it's like as soon as even a
man says that even though he's hot
worried like that it's kind of like it
seems like he's saying something
demeaning something wrong like yeah and
this is I think about the differences
between men and women so there was
definitely a big passion of society of
translating and women are the same were
identical and I was one of those people
I get mad if someone said that men or
women are different
because that well that means women are
going to lose in the workplace we need
to be equal in order to succeed and
that's just not true now I can
appreciate that I have feminine gifts
that the world needs and my relationship
needs that I
value I didn't even know what those were
but when you look at the word respect
through a feminine brain a lot of times
we think of it as something you're
obligated to give like to a parent or a
teacher or a boss and so it's been a
journey for me to really understand
where spread looks like to my husband
and appreciate it I used to think I was
being respectful if I let him know where
I was or I didn't believe him that and
got him nothing to do with respect for
him
for him it was respectful when I didn't
second-guess him or try to control them
or try to improve him and I didn't
always have to agree with his thinking
but I honor his thinking and I can do
that by using this magical three word
phrase that I rely heavily on these days
and that phrase is I hear you I hear you
it's just three words but it listen no
I'm not agree I'm not disagreeing but
I'm very witness you know what you say
is important to me I'm taking it on
board I'm giving it consideration I'm
giving it airtime and that's because I
respect you so that's one great and I
actually use that phrase with almost
everybody I talked to now my my sister's
and you know my friends and the people
on my team because everyone loves to
feel heard and understood yeah I like
that I hear you yes real these are like
these are the skills you talk about
techniques and I know as a martial
artist I mean you can really be exerting
a lot of strength if you don't have the
proper technique I could be going at it
with a really strong big guy and he's
much stronger bigger let's say he weighs
100 pounds more than me but now if I
have the proper technique I can use
science now leverage and technique to
overpower this person same thing here
you can apply the techniques now that
you're providing you know and through
years 18 was 18 years you said of
dealing with you know different helping
people to avoid divorce and implementing
these techniques and then having the
profound results that you're seeing is
truly amazing let's go on to I believe
this is number five we're going we're
going to we're going to do a lot more
we're just going to do a couple
or marriages not true or false you guys
are keeping score no cheating okay so as
soon as I read it
one will say true one will say false and
then you can tally up in your mind write
it down and see who want at the end
marriage is where the wife is feminine
soft and the husband is masculine are
highly successful what do you guys say
true or false true or false and the
answer is true
and you mentioned yin and yang go
together beautifully please elaborate on
this I think they've been this trend
towards like men have to be more
sensitive or whatever women have to go
out and you know kill it out in the
world as far as being a you know the
boss lady at work you know really kick
some butt out there and for me I know
when I really get down to it I'm really
honest one of the most important things
to me is to feel desired and to feel
loved
so there's so important to me and what
my husband is really attracted to is my
feminine mind body and spirit and so the
more receptive I am that's the essence
of femininity by the way is receptivity
so when I'm willing to accept his gifts
and compliments and his health and not
that from him but like from anybody from
everybody in the world that makes me so
much more attractive and then what I'm
attracted to about him is his manliness
you know there's time when and kind of
funny cuz it's such the opposite of
feminine that it looks really strange
sometimes
and yet I'm all like you know what
that's hot like he's acting really manly
right now even though and so and what is
that looks like he's like decisive you
taking initiative right he's
accomplishing things in the world that's
super exciting for me and so the way to
keep that excitement and exhilaration in
marriage alive is to set those gender
contrast a high and the way I can do
that is by showing up really feminine in
my relationship now it doesn't take away
from my success in the world a New York
Times bestselling author and this book
the Empowered wife is debated to a TV
series on
and I do lots of media I've got an
international coaching company so I'm
also I'm listed up much higher than I
would be if I didn't have this inner
strength that I get from this masculine
feminine contrast in my marriage I don't
know if you've heard the expression no
man wants another man in the house
where you know exhibiting what your is
is this correct what you're saying to
translate feminine to being soft to
exhibit those those those those really
those gifted qualities that a woman why
her creators been blessed with to
exhibit more of those that soft nature
right she can melt a man away with that
right absolutely this is probably
because of the feminine and what is
their magnetism our desire because
that's so much the directional for
husbands right they're like what does
she want
okay how's the direction we're going
right that's how he does what to do and
what actions to pursue and then as I
mentioned receptivity is the essence of
femininity the desire is the seat of
feminine power I can wear you know what
you desire and you can honor that and
express it clearly oh my god I mean
women can move mountains without moving
a muscle
or they know what their desires are
right I mean I'm going to get really
inspired to fulfill on those when I know
what they are
yeah there's cases where women just with
her with her look says to her husband
her voice it she projects it in two
different scenarios two different ways
and one can just just render him
unconscious and another way you know the
other ways she could just melt him you
know in a way that only a woman can do
to her husband so it's you know these
are there were the powerful yeah one of
the things that you know I created the
protection make you feel calm chief
aides that help you get into that that
mode right you use this phrase
I'm not going to connect you to your
vulnerability for instance which is
because another feminine gift is our
emotional brilliant
and then try to rely on us to bring that
homer bill yes the part of that
fascination that creates lasting
commitment it comes from our
vulnerability and so it's just pretty
magic to use these phrases and have them
kind of naturally pull you into that
moment and you see or you see that look
on your husband's page right I just
remember when I started practicing the
skills one time I came through this door
and staple it up to see me and I just
knew like wow this is working and that's
a lot of what we do receive the interest
assails diseases phrases that put it
into that mode brilliant next one
most people get divorced true or false
most people who get divorced are happier
with in a few years than they were when
they were unhappily married
okay so true or false what do you guys
have to say and Laura Dawe tells us
false studies she says studies show that
people are just as unhappy after they
divorced as they were and difficult in a
difficult marriage please elaborate on
this well I didn't sinister reason that
happiness is a personal responsibility
and so for me I made it about my husband
I wasn't happy because he was right
there and I thought all the time so I
kind of connected these dots falsely
I've been happy because I am well I was
unhappy because of me sadly and if I had
divorced him I can look back now and
she's really obviously how I would have
found somebody else and gone through the
same exact pattern or I would have been
alone and I'm happy just because that
was what I was used to that was my habit
so it really took this enormous effort
in the beginning to some focus to make
myself happy and then of course that in
a long way towards making my
relationship happy a lot of the other
intimacy fails if you can't expect to
get happy it it is fantasy that someone
else's actions or presence has to do
with your happiness right we are all you
can be happy in any circumstance and
that sounds nice to say but how how
powerful is it to start practicing that
where
are right now in this moment and
whatever state your marriage is in but
so we're almost finished here let's get
a couple more we're done with the quiz
exciting to be able to take this quiz is
right out of her book and it really has
you thinking and you've probably heard a
lot a lot of these different statements
for marriage to improve both people have
to work on it so for a marriage to I
know I've heard this so many times for
mayors to improve both people have to
work on it true or false
according to empowered wife Laura Doyle
false women have fought far more power
in the relationship pay attention here
and therefore have the ability to
revitalize the intimacy of a marriage
single-handedly that's like your
definition of superwoman men rise to the
occasion but women set the tone people
are like what are you talking about
please accelerate on this absolutely so
what we see over and over again I had
the honor of witnessing thousands of
times now is a wife gets her hands on
the intimacy skills she doesn't even say
to her husband hey I'm practicing these
energy company doesn't even know she's
doing anything and she'll say in about
two weeks she's like I feel like I have
a new husband he still thoughtfully so
considerate he held my hand in the car
for the first time in ten years you know
or I mean we can start with situations
that are very dire where maybe they've
been estranged for years living under
the same roof but sleeping in separate
bedrooms or maybe their divorce is
already started or sometimes there's an
affair going on it's amazing which she
can do by yourself so this was my body
Institute right I thought I was totally
stuck waiting for my husband to improve
himself and I told him how to improve
himself and he wouldn't do it
so I was trapped fit empowerment where
is it disguised and that disguise is
accountability that is taking
responsibility for what you're bringing
to the party in your marriage and
bringing this with such good news
because it was so important to me to
have a wonderful relationship I wanted
that more than anything like that
right the the greatest thing you'll ever
alert is just to love you love in return
and this is important to a lot of women
so it's great news
we have the power to make our
relationships intimate passionate and
playful who doesn't want that
yeah I know you're doing this power away
by not using it correctly I mean I think
that it's brilliant
and what's not all right no one ever
showed me I did not ever train you how I
smell like you didn't know how to make
an omelet or play the piano mechanic oh
gosh I hope I'm good at senta's so it's
not your fault if no one ever showed you
to skill so tell me now I wanted to
touch upon before we conclude I
mentioned science you know science now
through empirical observation you this
is this is science now science is where
you have tested it's not just to one's
your graphical location is it it's not
just here in the United States no yeah
no I see languages in 30 countries what
how many letters my good letters from
women in Japan like handwritten notes
you saved my marriage or in Egypt they
wrote and said we not only indigenous or
the way you're describing you know so it
surprised me here and American
appreciating things and my daughter from
Germany so your study with me is what I
said resonated so much with her
experience so we're just in Israel
amazing fumbling there and then truly
international from all over so this is
tested this is not just a theory this is
in practicality thousands of people have
benefited from this by implementing it
by being open-minded and trying it okay
you tried it that way your way okay but
you can't have the you know relationship
function on Burger King have it your way
all the time if somebody is giving you
the skills that are proven effective and
that's the science behind it because
it's actually working for these people
why not try it you'd be a fool if you
didn't yeah this is definitely proven in
like lots of different languages all
over the world and women from a variety
of pace you know I've been so honored to
be invited into
Muslim circles you know women that pay
too and say this matches exactly what
we're taught in our faith could it
explain how to do it so I was very
touched by that gradual things here that
I can I could substantiate that because
there is a strong emphasis in Islam
everything the roles are you know the
woman is given such a high standard that
she's given she's honored so much there
and she's the man has a role the woman
has a role but I like what what she
actually said you explained it and any
Muslim reading to say wow this is this
Islamic concept it's there but it's your
Laura Doyle is explaining it it's
amazing I mean tell us of the ne T you
call it needless emotional turmoil can
you elaborate on that sure so I spend a
lot of time in my anytime I'm trying to
control come on outside me come in I
can't control it causes love and these
emotional turmoil I caught any P that
for sure so no I got empowered a lot of
net and that's a good string I can pull
to figure out where did I get off of my
side of the street you know I caught my
paper item my papers were all my
decisions and choices and my attitudes
are that I can control my husband has
been on paper and anytime I try to jump
on his paper is just likely to be
exhausting and you know what was really
fascinating about this dude that when I
stop trying to be like the armchair
quarterback at my husband's life and
what you say our armchair course
accessible yeah yeah
yeah she's on that attitude we want to
do that yeah I think stop doing that you
know my life emerged and I got to write
these books and go and show isn't speak
lie in front of a live audience of
hundreds of people which you know what
it was terrifying
I was trying to avoid that because as
you scared to do it
so so much of the journey has just been
about finding the courage finding my
faith you know becoming a woman of faith
who trusts not just in my husband but
really is something much bigger than
that do you cover in your book also
helping people gain emotional stability
because one thing is these things are
logical it makes sense but sometimes
emotions can overtake someone emotional
stability you cover anything in your
book on that right so for me and I went
through a whole period of kind of being
focused on these disorders mental
disorders that are in like Diagnostic
and Statistical Manual so I was
diagnosed with depression and I have my
husband diagnosis attention deficit
disorder so we don't have some breakdown
along those line I was I was on
medication and therapy so you they
diagnosed they give out those diagnosis
is really easy into medications it's
fast like candy I remember my burgers
wasn't qualified to diagnose it so she
pulled us over here and you can get that
diagnosis though she was telling us oh
yeah you guys have it you got to go get
treat apart well neither's is on
medication now I don't have depression
he doesn't seem to have a very
successful business hand now so the the
emotional issues were bad habit they
were just as road that I went down
because I didn't know any other option
and as soon as I learnt and I had some
other choices and and not to say I mean
I'm so grateful now that these are my
new habits and they kind of carry me
along and they're perfect sylia and it's
like one of the key phrases that we use
is the word out right so I used to think
if you have a good marriage your husband
would never hurt your feelings and that
is just not true when you look so close
together I didn't mean to be never
intend to hurt my feelings
so sometimes were cheating each other or
whatever sometimes somebodies inpatient
whatever he hurts my feelings and so I
thought well that means my marriage is
broken and hopeless but now I just know
I just want to know and I just knew this
one word I'll just say ouch
and I'm not accusing him of anything I'm
not say anything but my husband just
immediately reacts and I've see houses
all over the world do this to raise like
oh oh my gosh I'm so sorry and intended
me to hurt your feelings or you know I
should have said
better you know he apologized right away
kind of a miracle really seems like I
that's what I've always wanted him to do
before it he never would do it and now
he's really quick to apologize just
taking that vulnerable approach and
keeping the connection alive by just
honoring what's true for me it's been
really powerful and magical oh why do
you you have this and I and I figured
this out but for someone who it's a
Putsch a powerful quote and I and I
think about it's really sad that you
know you get these diagnoses and you go
through spending all this money on the
conventional way and at the end you just
you hit a dead end and some people
there's a there's a profound you know
really intelligent dr. Brogan Kelly
Brogan who talks about this she's more
of a holistic now psychiatrist she used
to go prescribing these drugs and giving
these diagnoses she stopped she saw I'm
not helping people I'm actually making
people more sick she helps people get
off these drugs and she talks she talks
about you know all of the negative side
effects from people on these drugs and
people end up becoming psychotic in many
killing themselves or whatnot I mean
thank God you didn't you didn't end up
you know going down their route with so
many people it's it's an epidemic people
they get these diagnosis now they're
crippled by that they feel like there's
no hope for me they're stuck
but then happy true yeah I mean I found
it very alluring okay this is going to
be dissolution I am in a lot of pain and
this is going to help and it really
didn't happen anyway then I had a story
where I was depressed and my husband's
have his disorder a deficit disorder I
mean is that a label anybody wants to
carry around with them and not a good
thing to focus on what you focus on
increases so we absolutely have that
experience of it just making things
worse and I used to know that there was
an alternative you know that I could
practice these skills that they'd be so
simple like any woman can do them where
I you know none of that would have
mattered it does
opportunity and all where I never think
about depression or attention deficit
disorder and we do the same thing with a
you know one of the own in hilarious
things is a therapist once told me that
every time she reads a woman the
symptoms of Asperger's every single
month she go oh my gosh my husband have
that Asperger's is not even something
that people diagnosed me more they do
not autistic spectrum or whatever but
because she said that winneth and I said
putter in the description are like oh my
gosh my husband has got like something
on that unlike I do that I want to see
some of these things that we're calling
disorders or syndromes or deficits are
just part of the differences in the
genders and that is probably what makes
life exciting and makes relationships
interesting and exhilarating we were all
the same it'd be pretty boring yeah I'm
really enjoying getting all this great
data from you and having you on the
program I know we got to cut it she'll
like curtail it in a few I just I want
to get a couple more things in someone
mentions he says in your book do you
cover this the the the good about
bringing up someone keeps bringing up
the past if someone just keeps on like
every time you know you're moving
forward and then someone just starts
bringing things up from yesterday a year
ago a week ago ten years ago I mean is
revisiting this kind of history good for
the relationship
oh and fairness I just want to say this
is how we were all trained right that is
what therapy well welcome back to your
child has go back to pass not compute
out and I've been insulting right so
this is where we all got that idea and
no absolutely not it's not it's not if
what I'm doing is taking up over
resentment or alter of course that's not
going to serve me because that becomes
now my focus right that you let the
headline of our situations I oh my gosh
you once insulted me in front of my
family or whatever it's true
like wow just this morning you took me
out to breakfast and you know we went
for a walk hand and hand like and you're
working hard to support our family and
you clean the kitchen right like if I
focus on those things my husband just
automatically seems like my Sara and if
I'm focused on his mistakes I know this
is going to be perfect but my husband is
perfect for me yeah that's been bad bed
and buried why it's like digging up the
dead what are you doing that [ __ ] yeah
in fact a lot of them we may arrive in
our campus madam with a pay date a lot
have this abuse in my childhood this is
what happened to me and that and you
know I'd rather be open and I can go
through that one of my first because I
think it's like yeah I don't care about
any of that
oh good good we're just going to learn
some skills over here and that's going
to going to really alleviate a lot of
the pain that you're feeling that you
think is related to these five incidents
you know anything about like a teenager
who's trying to get a job we don't say
well maybe the reason you're not getting
a job is because what happened when you
were eight what about when you were
eight you know you would say okay let's
help you write a resume let's pop you of
your interview skills let's take your
friends and potential employers right
we're going to say like you know maybe
when you're eight you crashed your bike
you know that you're going to get a job
or I can't it's kind of silly if you
look at it that way do it okay how can
people get the books empowered wife
where can people get the book well every
chapter of it uh gift cherish comment
sort of women wants you did cherish
enough it's going to do but we all have
something fun going on right now to get
cherish challenge where I'll send you a
little experiment child your marriage
every day for five days you can try one
of the little cheap creams to see how
works for you see if you want to keep it
or if it doesn't work for you of course
you can throw it out but we find they
are very effective for women all over
the world so I can cherish calm to do aa
we had such a great response last time
euro for your previous show you did
people are asking when are you going to
do if you haven't already have it on
audio on have the book on
on audio audio book is that in the plan
are you going to do anything like that
actually inaudible no no it is on audio
bit under a different title and the
title is called first Hill of America
okay okay you can listen to it on audio
also where we're not is it on Kindle
what about how does audible we can get
an audible until I get it on audible
yeah okay and if if someone wants to
become people in the communities they
want to empower the people in their
communities with this information they
want to become a coach now right like
you are how can they how can they also
get involved and do be a coach a
marriage coach what do you call it what
we call relationship emojis your school
huddle a resonation circuited yeah Lord
well certified relationship coaches we
do offer coach training periodically so
just reach out to me you can write to me
at Laura at Laura Doyle org if you're
called to be a coach commercial women
are attracted to this amazing women are
attracted to spreading this message and
getting the skills out especially in
their community and so we really love
that I would love to hear from women who
are passionate about that like I am this
is my mission to end world wars and
mission calls to you too I don't want to
hear from you thank you so much you guys
empower wife get the book I want to
thank you so much it was a pleasure last
time and this time and thank you for the
wonderful card thank you so much god
bless you I really appreciate the work
that you're doing and the community does
we really you know if you guys want to
are you two also visiting places people
get you to come to their communities
they can also get hold you there to
bring you out yeah to come in to be
where there's a group of women any time
you know I was really excited I got
invited to be lovely to everyone Muslim
women and it was standing room only and
I probably rockstar and anybody wants me
to come there gosh I would
the iron guys you heard that in power
empower the women power the community
get her to your community and let us
know we'll help promote it
yeah Willie I want to thank you again
thank you so much god bless you thank
you Laurie thank you yeah my pleasure
you can so wonderful to me I can't thank
you enough
so much thank you